foreign
with us in Chattanooga hi Millie welcome
to the Ramsay show
what's up
I have a lesson to your shows uh from
the first time that you hit the airwaves
and uh your plan is worked for me over
the years I'm now 72 years old
I'm a happily retired in a beautiful
Mountain Home
I lived at pre for years and years
and so it's just my kind of folks it's
just uh it's just a great retirement
life when you are debt free and you have
all the money you need at retirement
amen Millie how about it and there's
some beautiful mountains around
Chattanooga to have a house on cool how
can we help today
well I ran into one dilemma and I guess
that's because my emotions are in this
one I always thought that I I did
excellent making the accounting
decisions over my lifetime and never
assembled anywhere
but uh I'm with it and uh so uh I'm
engaged
and uh the thing is that uh I love my
beautiful home retirement home that I
have built
and uh my fiancee uh he don't have the
financial means that I have and he lives
in a small little home on a farm
and I'm sitting here in 4 000 square
feet home with sun rooms Supreme porches
you name it I got it all and he's in
1100 square foot little small farmhouse
um he does not want to leave the farm to
live in my Mountain Home
and stuff like that why wouldn't he gets
you in the picture he gets you with the
deal
yes he gets me in the deal maybe I'm
just gonna have to kick him into bed I
don't know
Millie how far how far of a distance is
The Farmhouse and the Mountain House
15 minutes
and then keep his Farmhouse and he can
go there when he wants to hang out and
everything you can do weekends at the
farm keep both
but he has suggested that uh you know
that we live in his house and uh so
anyway he uh he wants me to or has
suggested now he's never asked me for
any money even though he has a small
social security income he's never asked
me for money and I'm not even since
childhood he has suggested that I invest
for about 150 to 200 000 in his home to
make it the home that I would be
comfortable in you know what I mean I
wouldn't do that
and so I can't see it because I
uh
the awful costly marriage license
[Laughter]
well I don't think that's necessary to
get married I think he's going to marry
you anyway because he's a smart man so
uh
we've been engaged over a year and the
families keep saying now I have no
children but his family is wonderful to
me so here's what I would do his house
is paid for right
yes your house is paid for right yes and
how much of a nest egg do you have kiddo
I I have over a million all right I I
would just leave his house as your
weekend property y'all both hang some
clothes and others after you're married
had some clothes in both houses uh I got
a lake house about an hour and 15
minutes south of my house and I love it
but I ain't gonna live down there it's
too far away and so but I'm down there
most weekends uh in the summer and a
couple of them in the winter and I keep
a set of clothes down there I just throw
a backpack in the car and I go down
there Sharon and I that's our second
home and you've got a wonderful Farm
beautiful little farm with a nice little
house on it that's your wonderful second
home and y'all go spend weekends on the
farm and weekdays up at the other place
or vice versa and keep them both but I
would not I would not improve that
property it's not what you want to do
Millie that's why I wouldn't do it
because you don't want to do it well
that and what is does he have a quick
reasoning to why he wants to stay in The
Farmhouse is he just like being by the
farm like what I wonder what his reason
is
well uh the house was built in 1905 and
it was his grandfather's and his
father's home and he would I would not
get rid of yeah don't yeah don't sell it
don't sell it but I wouldn't improve it
I would just use it as my weekend Farm
home
well I think that what I the conclusion
that I'm thinking of right now Dave
since you mentioned that is I think I'll
just uh take one extra bedroom in it and
build me a large walk-in closet
[Laughter]
yes when Millie's gonna hang some
clothes absolutely she's taking a
bedroom I'm just saying a hundred
percent